mais d'abord il a chanté sur les plus
belles scènes d'opéra européenne et même
fait une apparition dans james bond
et puis soudain plus rien pour sébastien
soul plus de contrats parce que plus de
concerts la photocopie 19 retour à blois
ou pour payer les factures le baryton a
troqué son costume pour un sac de
coursier paul le paul boyer la rencontre
et il est midi et comme chaque jour
sébastien se rend en centre-ville de
blocs pour travailler cet ancien
chanteur lyrique d'opéra reconnu à
l'international a troqué malgré lui ses
partitions contre à vélo depuis six mois
il livre des repas pour vivre j'ai 25
ans de scène derrière moi et jusqu'au 29
février 2019 en 2020 pardon 2020 on sait
plus on en est gt gt sur scène j'ai
chanté le 5 février 2020 à l'opéra
d'athènes encore et puis du jour au
lendemain en quelques jours tout s'est
arrêté
je suis en ligne et donc à partir de
maintenant on n'attende pas de course
quand tout-à-coup donc une course de 6
km 6 km c'est que l'aléa le retour se
fera 12 c puis 8 euros 63 il y aura une
double commande vous prenez tout celle
là je vais la prendre
raison de preuves
pas le temps de traîner une journée lui
rapporte aux alentours de 60 euros à les
passionnés de cyclisme il n'a pas voulu
se laisser aller en revenant à blois
après plusieurs courses le chanteur
livreur prend enfin une pause ce
m'arrange pour essayer de gagner à peu
près de pédaler au temps qu'il faut pour
gagner dans les 1000 euros par mois ce
qui permet de couvrir les frais du
quotidien et avec un peu de son fils par
rapport à ce que je faisais avant
ça passera 10 % donc quand est ce que
j'aurais dû faire ça là honnêtement là
je ne sais pas là les courses
s'enchaînent tout au long de la journée
de retour chez lui sébastien on profite
pour continuer de s'exercer à son métier
principal le champ à l'après midi
j'essaie un peu de m'entretenir la voix
et de bon il ya peut-être un peu une
lueur que quelques concerts reviennent
ici quelques semaines quelques mois
j'avoue que j'avais vraiment
complètement arrêté de chanter pendant
six mois j'ai pas pas chanter une note
pendant six mois puis là depuis quelques
semaines j'essaie un peu de me remettre
sébastien soul espère un jour remonter
sur scène d'ici là le chanteur d'opéra
de blois continuera de livrer vos repas